imagine looking through Netflix to chill
and then seeing your real life becoming
a new series that everyone can watch
online every action of yours is
immediately filmed by actors and
streamed everywhere how is this possible
your phone is your enemy which is
constantly being listened to 24 7.
and you don't even notice what you're
agreeing to so how our series created so
quickly streambury's system uses a
quantum computer to create thousands of
Series in just minutes using AI versions
of celebrities so-called deep fakes to
portray the users all over the world
there is no legal basis there's no way
we can sue these guys but if we destroy
this computer system that's all happened
to Joan from a new episode of Black
Mirror so what do you think how soon
will it become our reality write your
opinion in the comments